do you remember one time I'd then asked
another person out on a date after I got
engaged
Hannah Brown throws some not so subtle
shade at Tyler Cameron the Bachelorette
turned Dancing with the Stars contestant
is featured in Cosmopolitan's expensive
taste test and didn't shy away from
talking about her former beau and his
recent outings with gigi hadid
but first she referenced her
relationship with Jed Wyatt whom she
broke up with after learning he still
had a girlfriend when he went on the
show don't remember that one time I was
engaged remember that one time I got
engaged
oh we remember all right where does your
relationship stand now I am NOT with Jed
anymore then Hannah said this Jeremy not
one time I then asked another person out
on a date and then just uh yeah we
remember that too I just thought maybe
we could go for a drink and just say it
don't you just tell me what I'm not of
course we all know how that turned out
you guys got that drink huh yeah I had
some drink how did it go I have a great
time
just days after they got that drink
Tyler was spotted out with Gigi I saw
feelings but I'm also single and he's
single and I want to keep my options
open and he can keep his options I've
been ET recently caught up with Hanna's
pal bachelor in paradise star crystal
Nielsen and she revealed how Hannah took
the news and she felt a little hurt with
Tyler I told her that it's not easy you
don't need to be perfect you don't need
to be the strong woman to get through
this with Tyler it's okay to open up
your heart and share that you're hurt
you're struggling and I go you've been a
strong amazing lead because of your
vulnerability and your willingness to
show your imperfections and embrace them
and love yourself and that's why America
loves you now it seems Hannah might be
ready to hit the dating scene I need to
get a dating app right now because I am
commodity I have some cheap tastes and
in true Alabama Hannah fashion she poked
fun at herself and this awkward moment
from her time on Colton Underwood season
of The Bachelor
yeah I started it what's he saying let's
make a toast to let's take a taste to
put some words together just so put a
bunch of words that sound good that are
real they're real
okay I don't
[Music]